[Music]
today
we are very very honored to be joined by
a man who is an historian he's a host
he's a christian thinker he's a cultural
warrior a man who has written many books
books such as
if you can keep it very important to be
reading right now
books on william wilberforce books on
dietrich bonhoeffer
books on martin luther and i think
perhaps most importantly
books such as donald drains the swamp
donald builds the wall and donald
and the fake news there are a lot you
know you can understand very prolific
very wide cultural net here eric mataxis
thank you
for being here i you know whenever i'm
introduced like that that i think like i
should just leave because it can only go
downhill from here
only i can only disappoint people so
thank you
i am oh and also i should mention yes
the host of the eric mataxis show the
host of the aircraft you know that the
name the earthquake show was not taken
and we grabbed it
and so now i'm the host so now you've
got to do it that's good it's good to
find that
i am amazed by how prolific you are
because i've got to tell you something
i've only done one book ever in my life
it's called reasons to vote for
democrats a comprehensive guide
it was completely blank it was a blank
book it was a blank book well can i tell
you
i got a couple of years on you okay when
i was your age
i don't think i had done anything except
write children's books i've written 30
children's books people don't know that
about me but
you have a lot of time thank you you're
kind of busy yeah i'd like you to take
some pressure off yourself oh well i
appreciate it
because you know all of these things
you're working in right now
it seems like each one of them is more
urgent than the next
that's the problem you can kind of divvy
it up into the culture that's the
problem into history
into religion yeah right now we're in an
election year
what i know yeah you know i actually had
sort of forgotten because
everything's just about the virus or the
yeah blm or this or that
yeah so it seems to me this is kind of
the book that people need to focus on
if you can keep it yes and the subtitle
the forgotten promise of american
liberty
the urgency i wrote that book four or
five years ago
the urgency is that we in america
have forgotten most most people maybe
not people who watch this show but
most people have forgotten the glorious
idea of liberty and what it actually
means we kind of go like what what's the
it's kind of like the fish doesn't
understand the water like what what do
you mean what what what
it is a wild insane idea it never should
have succeeded
the fact that it succeeded and has
lasted this long and is on the verge of
disappearing because we've forgotten
about it
there is an urgency that is not even
slightly overstated and i
i said i want to write a book that kind
of puts everything you need to know
in one book so that people will get it
and i
promise you michael if someone reads
this book
that i don't need to tell them anything
else they will
they will think of a thousand things
that they could do or want to do
once they get it well you know the line
it's famous line of benjamin franklin
which is what have you done at this
constitutional convention he says we've
created a republic
if you can keep you now have statues
falling down of thomas jefferson and
george washington you've got half the
country is like up in flames
at the moment yeah can we keep it well
i'm a christian and i believe that
god commands us to be hopeful
and to keep fighting and that to despair
is sin
to sit on your hands and say it's all
going up in flames and let's just you
know wait for jesus to return
that is sinful that is wrong it is
morally wrong
i also believe that we will keep it
but it's like if you ask somebody in
1860 can we hold
the the country together it's going to
be a fight
but it's a fight worth fighting it's a
fight
worth taking on because
so many people defend depend on us
right everyone listening fighting for
what is right
and and if you were in germany in the
30s
if you there are plenty times when you
think if people would do the right
thing everything can change well
this is such an important aspect though
which is
it requires you to do something you you
need an act of the will
you hear on the left they say that
they've got the science of history right
there yeah it's a history is moving in
their direction
first of all that's a a joke of a lie
no but i mean you need to say that yeah
it is absolutely nonsense and you need
to push back hard because
so many people believe that that is
garbage and that's that's obviously
garbage
but you do see this complacency with
conservatives yes i know
they say so well you know look it'll
work out in the end yeah at some point
uh
at least we can pray and hopefully go to
the right place yeah but we
we are called upon to do to preserve
something to conserve something
anybody who says you know the latter
part of what you just said that is
foolishness
yeah but it's worse than foolishness
it's deep it's grave irresponsibility
the fact of the matter is that if you
want to be
governed by someone else yeah a tyrant
a bureaucratic critic tyranny whatever
it is
uh you don't really need to do anything
except what they tell you
if you want to be free you
must do something and in america we have
traditionally made that choice we say
we're going to do what it takes to
govern ourselves to keep ourselves free
we're going to do that work because we
know that if we don't
someone will step in yeah and someone
will govern us
and they will govern us in such a way
that it's not just that we're not
governing ourselves we will genuinely
not be free we will lose
things will go downhill uh we won't
create as much wealth as much
opportunity so
if you care about other people for
example if you care about the black
urban
poor yeah and you do not
fight for this republic
you are doing nothing
in other words i know that god cares
about the poor yeah
and i know that our entire way of life
is about trying to do what we can
usually in the private sector to help
the poor so if you say nothing
when a marxist organization like black
lives matter takes over and antifa takes
away
if you go well whatever you are harming
children poor children in other words we
have a responsibility for them
like if we don't care about ourselves
that's that's fine but but there are
generations depending on us
now fighting this fight and and yes
god is judging us yeah right no i mean
that that's like no pressure
god is judging us because you look at
public opinion polls
four out of five black americans do not
want to defund the police
but blm says we're going to defund the
police especially in these terrible
neighborhoods
obviously that's not going to work out
very well speaking of the black
community
and speaking of liberty you know 2020 is
a weird
year when one of the finest articulators
of liberty around
is kanye west did you see kanye west
recently
he was giving i suppose a campaign
speech and he said
liberty is not just doing whatever you
want liberty
is also not looking at the pornography
liberty is putting down the percocet
liberty
but most conservatives don't know that
exactly okay
well that's because he's a christian and
because if you're a christian with a
brain
you understand and that's what i write
about and if you can keep it
self-government and liberty mean
i have to govern myself we're not just
talking about a system of
self-government quote unquote right it
means
i must govern myself all the founders
understood this all of the founders not
not the christian founders every one of
the founders including franklin and
jefferson understood
that if we have a virtuous people who
will govern themselves usually that
comes
from faith usually yeah then we can be
free but if we don't there is no form
there's no checks and balances there's
nothing we can do
to prevent it from going into some kind
of tyranny or anarchy or whatever it is
so kanye west gets this because he has
struggled with various addictions and
and this and that so he's put these
pieces together
you know half the people the none of the
never trumpers get this but i'm saying
that like
half of the people that are social
conservatives barely make this
connection between faith and freedom and
so
to my mind uh this is i mean it's why i
wrote this book but it's also kind of a
moment
in our history where we're we're getting
a glimpse of the
horror yeah of the other side's fruit
well i i see this image as you're
describing of conservatives kind of
shrugging their shoulders right
yeah one thing you often hear yeah and
it's a true statement for what it's
worth is
politics is downstream of culture
correct but that's not an excuse just to
shrug you and say okay well we can't do
anything yeah
no well politics is downstream of
culture but
then there's plenty you can do in the
culture you know what i'm saying like
uh not uh not looking at pornography
would be step one you know not giving
money to anything
that is harming the culture and and
listen this is i mean it's it's why i do
a lot of the writing and the
types of things that i do is i feel like
we have neglected the culture
and it's kind of like fighting a war and
you're getting killed and you don't
understand why we we've got more boots
on the ground and more tanks and more
wherever we go and then you realize oh
we forgot the air force they have an air
force yeah
we don't have a plane in the sky the
culture
is like the air force if you've got air
cover it changes the whole
battle we have neglected i mean think of
uh is there a talk show okay whether
it's conan
or you know go down the line that is
either
conservative or not anti-trump
or what in other words here you have at
least 50 percent of the country
that has that point of view but all of
those major shows are coming from a
secular humanist liberal
hate trump hate conservative world view
right
that's not the free market that's like a
weird monopoly and we have
uh we meaning conservatives traditional
people people of faith
have allowed that to happen and then we
complain that the culture is going to
hell i love that this too because this
is another one of these shrug your
shoulders excuses they say well look
it's the free market every single
television show is left-wing every
single one yeah that's the
but you know what that's like saying
that's like saying like like we have a
free market like we got some slave
states we go say we go get
and if you're against slavery like just
just don't buy one
yeah like there's no moral issue yeah
it's just the free market is the only
morality
you're free not to buy let me tell you
the free market and again it's something
i talk about briefly in there but i've
talked about a lot
we need to understand the moral
component to capitalism and the more
component to democracy
for example if you believe as we believe
that mankind has fallen which even the
founders all understood why do we need
checks and balances
because you know power corrupts why
because that's people people
do not govern so there you go thank you
did you just think of that
okay so but but the point is if you
believe that you know that unless the
people are virtuous
generally speaking yeah they will vote
for hitler yeah
they they in other words the the idea
that we can vote is
meaningless unless we the people
know what is good choose what is good
news i could i could pick somebody
that's going to line my pocket
and wreck america or i could pick the
guy where i'm going to get
less money but he is going to help the
whole country yes okay a moral person
would vote for that guy okay same thing
with the free market the free market
if we want it's amoral it will deliver
better pornography better drugs better
it'll get it is amoral so anybody who
has fetishized made an idol of the free
market
does not even understand how the free
market works china
because of conservative and liberal uh
ignorance on uh on what's going on with
china by giving a most favored nation
status and on and on we know we thought
eventually they would be wearing tricorn
hats and
we now know it doesn't work that way
yeah
right it doesn't you know i've only
realized this in the past few years with
all the kind of
tumult and in the conservative movement
it seems to me conservatives have just
focused on the form of politics the
procedure of power the way it looks
but not the substance like for you you
would always hear this thing
it doesn't matter who you vote for just
that you vote right that's like saying
like
it doesn't matter what faith you have as
long as you believe in something yeah
okay
i believe in hitler and satan yeah so
that's fine right
like that's the point that doesn't make
any sense
it matters what we do what we stand for
in this idea look it's just the free
market
just as long as we have this form of the
framework now you have to be doing
something in there too
the only reason people say that is
because they they have been blessed to
live in a world
where most people culturally
choose the right things but that but
that has been going downhill quickly and
we are beginning
unfortunately to see the horrific fruit
of cultural decline and what happens
when the free market begins delivering
you know just look at netflix it's like
it's like blood
satan sex like suicide what what
what what is uplifting what are we
creating that's uh that's uplifting
right right and
you think that doesn't have an effect on
the 12 year old kid
like you you don't care about all those
kids they're growing up in this world
like
you know god will judge you for that you
need to think about them what are you
what are you putting in front of them
and if you think the free market will
save them from that
you don't understand the free market for
how long did the republican party
in every one of their fundraising
speeches defend corporate america as
though the
giant corporations they're the most
wonderful thank goodness for the
corporate america has has pushed the
country to the left
more than maybe any institution other
than and i think that the founders this
is the one thing the founders
couldn't quite see in others they
couldn't quite predict
the craveness of corporate america i
have no problem
calling it demonic there is a level
let me just tell you in other words if
the if if nike and other companies are
willing to use slave labor
in china to make an extra buck how are
they morally different
from the people who use jewish slave
labor they worked with the nazis they
said you know what if we don't do it
somebody else is going to do it i might
as well get the prophet
what about the people that said okay
you we're going to trade with the south
and you you've got slaves but like i
don't i just don't care
that's your business it's everybody's
business mankind is our business to
quote uh
to quote uh uh dickens uh in scrooge and
in christmas carol uh we we are to be
about our father's business to quote
jesus
um and we are our brother's keeper and
if you
do business with a corporation
or a country that is allowing
slave labor uh and other violations of
human rights
you are guilty okay and so a lot of
people would be very quick to say
um oh if i'd been alive in germany i
certainly wouldn't have said okay
well you are alive in germany what are
you doing now minute
yeah and you have a choice okay are you
going to hold the nba's feet to the fire
are you going to hold nike's feet to the
fire apples feet to the fire google's
feet to the fire
all of these companies to my mind and
there's so many
they do not have any moral conviction
it's only about the bottom line
that is [ __ ] behavior it is a moral
behavior if you care about human beings
you cannot do that and we need we need
to call them to account
right what what does it conserve if nike
can make an extra buck by exploiting
slave labor in china
you one thing i think conservatives
often when they when they shrug their
shoulders they leave it at politics it's
downstream of culture
they ignore the amount to which uh
politics can affect culture that's sort
of another point
but one thing i love about what you do
is you go that step further
and if politics is downstream of culture
well what is culture downstream of
cult and culture come from the same root
word right it's downstream of
religion i i'm reminded of that line
from from henry edward cardinal manning
who said
at bottom all human conflict is
theological
as much as conservatives in america are
kind of waking up to
shaking off the the platitudes of the
last 30 years
do they get that part yet well i i think
folks like
you and me are doing our best to help
them understand it i mean in the
in the book if you can keep it and i
didn't show up here to plug that book
but it's like all these ideas are in
that book
but you know this too okay you cannot
divorce
anything from anything else your your
faith
is connected to virtue which is
connected to self-government and liberty
so if you value liberty and a free
system you cannot get away from those
ideas
so any libertarian who thinks you can is
flat out wrong the math
doesn't work so these things are
connected
and once we in this culture you know
roughly 50 years ago
when we took prayer out of the schools
when we had the sexual revolution
something happened in the culture a
shift happened
and in effect we divorced you know as a
catholic
uh i can tell you and you know once
mary eberstadt's book uh you know once
the pill
created a technology to divorce sex
from children and family something
happened
in the culture and we've watched that
work its way out
over 50 years okay
and we now see that these things have to
go hand in hand we have to talk in our
schools in our public schools
about virtue about right about wrong
about dignity
and honor we have to talk about the
honor of george washington
in doing what he did once you cease to
teach those things and teach
cease to teach heroes and cease to teach
what makes america great
once you cease to do that you you have
opened a way
for you know lincoln talks about it a
free people's suicide right
that that eventually we will destroy
ourselves one once we take our eye off
that ball and that's
sort of what we've been doing the last
50 years and the sexual revolution has
just made it
you know uh more and more obvious and
here we are
and here well that's the point yeah sure
because you've you've mentioned
prayer in schools you've mentioned
reading the bible i mean things that you
are not allowed you're not even allowed
to utter that suggestion
yeah because what we are told by the
popular culture is
if you talk about virtue if you talk
about the bible if you talk about
christianity
that is pushing that's indoctrinating
your point of view yeah and
and so i guess the premise of that is
that the public schools as they are now
yeah
are totally neutral they're valuable but
that's the whole point that's the joke
and that's why
conservatives and traditional people and
people of faith
if you don't push back you deserve to be
pushed into the corner because you're
you are you are aligning yourself with
those who would push you in the corner
look what who gets to decide
what we can talk about in a free culture
you're telling me well you can talk
about climate change you can talk about
this okay but you can't
oh you can't talk about that i'm here to
say
that my faith and this constitution
says you're wrong we can talk about
anything we want and if we participate
in our own silencing
we're participating in the destruction
of freedom for all
not just for us for everybody we're
sewing off the branch that we're all
sitting on and so
the idea that you can take the concept
of virg i mean c.s lewis wrote about
this like in the 40s in his book
abolition of man he says you know we
we stop preaching about virtue we stop
talking about virtue and honor and
dignity and then we're shocked when we
find traitors and cowards in our midst
right
the fact of the matter is there has
never been a time when you can stop
talking about these things but because i
mean you you know richard john newhouse
wrote his book in 1984 the naked public
square
he made this argument he said the
founders created a system
where religion is free meaning the
government
cannot and will not force any kind of
faith
on the population because when you force
faith
you make it uh is something that that is
not free and natural
and voluntary and so you effectively
destroy it it doesn't work it doesn't
work it doesn't
work but if you keep it free in those
really believe in the free market of
ideas
you say let it ride let it go let's see
which ideas rise to the top
but something happened roughly 50 years
ago where people said well those ideas
you can't talk about and once you talk
about them
you're pushing for a theocracy okay well
we're here to say
the only way you will not have some kind
of a theocracy
a secular theocracy if you can say that
an agnostic atheist theocracy i mean
forced uh kinds of thinking the only way
to avoid that
is on the founders model which says that
faith the faith of the bible is it's the
only kind of faith
that cannot and will not impose itself
it proposes itself but it can't impose
itself so the point is like
if you don't talk about this then
politically correct woke maniacs
will tell you what to think that would
be worse
than a christian theocracy or it
certainly would be equal to a christian
theocracy
but i don't know a single christian
who's advocating for the theocracy so
we have to really push back and say like
there's no one talking about this you're
crazy and what do we even mean by
theocracy i mean i always love when
people
who are imposing the gnostic dualism of
transgender ideology
and saying that but you know they accuse
us
but that's the point they're gaslighting
us it's a joke and people need to wake
up and push back
and push back hard because the facts are
simply
not on their side but if they can shut
you up
they can just keep pushing and that's
what they've done well and you bring up
this point of history you know looking
at these guys like george washington
yeah and it occurs to me too
when you look back on guys like uh
jefferson even that howling atheist to
quote his opponents
or or washington or you go further back
to christopher columbus
and you look through them yeah with
through a christian lens right for
what they're doing what it means for
civilization what it means for the
spreading of the gospel
in particular to say nothing of their
other virtues
you have a different outlook on them
than if you look back on these guys
through the lens of explicit marxism
which we're seeing today
through the lens of an understanding of
human nature that is totally at odds
with what our founders believed
and with what happens to be the truth
it's that religious view
whether it's the secular religious view
or other it's that religious view that
gives color
to these historical figures so is it any
surprise they tear down the statues
well you're right and that's the point
is that they
they stood for all of those things and
really we're talking about a war
on the west yeah and a war
on god yeah i mean that that's what this
is
why is all marxism really
atheistic marxism now they don't
necessarily advertise that
but the point is there is no doubt that
you know that that all of these atheist
i mean all these marxist countries
were as viciously violently
atheist it's like out of a nightmare you
know
what they did to people of faith marx's
writings there's actually a good book
coming out by paul kanger
but it's we're plugging all these books
we'll plug paul's book it's called the
devil and karl marx
which goes into marx's writing some of
his poetry yeah so it's
good luck reading that stuff it's not
even just
explicitly atheist which it is it's
demonic
it's satanic and it is let's not
we don't have all the time in the world
let's cut to the chase that is correct
okay
and you need to call these things what
they are we have
not taught a hatred of marxism and
communism for the last 50 years now yeah
my parents taught me to hate it why
because my mother grew up in germany
which became east germany
she saw it my father in greece the greek
civil war he saw the communists
they knew the deep wickedness
and the deceit of communism and they
taught me to understand
that this is not anodyne this is not
harmless this is a a vicious enemy
and we now have enough young people in
america that never really got that
yeah and all they focuses on what's
wrong with with america and and i'm i'm
here to say that
black lives matter the organization and
that that whole thing and antifa
they are vicious cultural
marxist and their enemy is
the god of the bible i i talked about uh
in
in um in moby dick herman melville talks
about ahab who's like this demonic
figure he's he's animated by rage
what is this rage and at some point in
the book he says he wants to punch to
strike through the mask
of the sky he basically wants to kill
god he's so
angry and that rage that we see
on the radical left today it's that kind
of a rage there is not the beginning
of reasonableness anywhere to be found
it's a a destructive rage and if we
don't acknowledge that
and fight against it with law and order
and so on and so forth
we have no idea how bad things can get
and i think we need to begin to imagine
and we're getting some ideas this is the
key you can't divorce these things i
think a lot of people
look out and they see the statue
toppling and the blm and the crazy blue
hairs screaming on college campuses
and the the attacks on the churches they
see them all as
different phenomena they're not you
can't divorce those things
you've got to focus on on each level of
it which you can do by the way
in eric mataxis is 7000 books all of
which i recommend
on uh on well obviously if you can keep
it yeah on bonhoeffer
yeah on wilberforce on luther on
donald on donald choose your choose your
favorite
my luther book is the only
non-how do i put this i would consider
it a pro-catholic luther book
you know what i'm saying like i don't i
i got peter craig one of the greatest
catholic
apologists alive he loved the book
because i am uh i'm not catholic but i'm
pro-catholic and
and and luther is a fascinating i will
say i read the luther book and i did
enjoy it and even though i'm i'm really
a little more on the pope leo side of
that particular controversy
i really enjoyed that book as well and i
always love listening to you
eric mataxes find him on youtube in
particular before youtube kicks us all
off you can go to the eric mataxis show
channel you can also go to
ericmataxis.com you can find him all
over the place obviously on amazon
twitter twitter twitter myspace twitter
livejournal
everywhere on the old send audio
cassettes on carrier pigeons
eric thank you so much for being here my
privilege thank you
[Music]
you